they'll send hermon marcus to the mound
this afternoon he is two and five with a
435
era marcus at 227 seven home runs and 21
runs batted in
this one's driven toward the gap in
right center field polar can't get it
bounces off the wall marcus simeon with
the lead-off double
another row two swang and a miss they
threw
four consecutive curve balls to grossman
and ermond gets him to strike him out
for the first out
two away simeon goes to third and
olson's coming up
swung out of miss what a job by herman
olson
spikes his helmet two punch outs after a
lead off
double says uh-uh
and they will face that man right there
mike byers making his tenth start of the
season he's been throwing the ball well
over his last five outings
four and one 382 era and he's back where
it all began
kite made his major league debut right
here at coors field back on september 14
2011. charlie blackmon the dh this
afternoon towards center field
moriano's there and mike fires has a
three up three down bottom of the first
now the ants have a shot once again they
were all for three with
a runner in scoring position in the
first inning and now they have first and
second with one out and
is coming up and this is slowly hit
there's one on the first they still
double up ramon loriano
that's well done that's a center fielder
running another double play
turn by the rockies they're 52nd
is giving himself an issue here with the
walk and then the aaron pickoff throw
3-2 that's way inside and that's going
to be a wild pitch allowing kemp to go
to third and
semi into first three walks so
uncharacteristic of
hermann
bounces one and fuentes is going to
throw toward third his throw is high
and now in a rundown is kept and they're
gonna tag marcus simeon he's out the
throw to the plate and
kemp is safe unbelievable but then kemp
it looked like he was able to avoid the
tag
but watch here marcus simeone coming to
third and an incredible heads-up
effort from nolan aronado but tony kipp
on the backside
duck dive dodge duck and dive
tk so they're not gonna look at it so
that's gonna be a run for the eight
so walters at first mcmahon at third
rocky's down one nothing and here's
rymel tapia
and rymel loops to shallow center and
it is going to drop mcmahon now sprints
home
getting to second is walters everybody
kind of had to eyeball that one it works
out beautifully for the rockies
and it's a 1-1 ball game on the bloop
single by tapia
1-1 rockies and a's but arenado at third
and fuentes at first and only one out in
this fourth
and a huge strikeout as dahl missed it
strikeout number three for mike and now
mcmahon bats
mcmahon grounds it to kemp so fires is
going to get out of the inning nicely
done first and third one out and the
rockies
do not score tony had a base hit his
first time up
and this is in the air to right center
field and it is going to drop
it's going to be a tweeter and tony in a
second with a double it looked
like it was gonna hang up long enough
for canada to get there
it's this one to the right side olsen to
third and they
got him what a play by matt olson
you're supposed to hit the ground ball
to the right side do your job get the
runner over no problem right not with
ollie over there
rockies are one for seven in the clutch
this afternoon the a's are over seven
first pitch tapped back to fires he's
got it he'll underhand
a first and what a job by mike fires
with a little help from the goal glover
at first base
and the asep runners at second and third
and canada will check in
right back up the middle mcmahon has the
play
throws to first in time but la stella
comes in to score
so the a's grab the lead 2-1 and that'll
bring up jake lamb
another hit for lamb to olson who's
gonna trot in to score he was at third
and now it's three to one you hear the
rockies again they
have gotten base runners in multiple
innings but just the one run
we'll see if trevor story can keep this
going in the seventh
rocky's down three to one up here goes
and that is a swing and a miss on a 3-2
slider to trevor story so three
strikeouts in inning
we go to the bottom of the ninth inning
these lead the rockies 3-1
daniel murphy now to pinch it
and maybe another awkward swing and
another strikeout
rocky's down to their final out diaz
struck out as a pinch hitter in the
seventh inning
kicks and fires the one-two pitch that's
hit in the air right center
should be the ball game loriano's under
he's got it and that
is the ball game so these are ready to
come on home
as the magic number is down to five to
clinch the al's western division
the oakland athletics three and the
colorado rockies
one